here yep Grammy nominated again right
yep three times Grammy nominated one
time wi three last time you got [__]
you got uh what I like to call
snubbed run the Jews run the Jews got
snubbed that's what they say I just was
man I remember being broken hearted but
you were but you were right yeah R2 j4
should have been nominated I think so
yeah I think so yeah uh well listen it's
all good though because Michael is
nominated Killer Mike is here yep
welcome what's up you do have the album
of the year I have my list you're number
one my number two album is not even a
rap album but I'm going to do my hip-hop
list but you're number one by far man
thank you I said that to you too in
studio you mean I said I know a lot of
people just be saying crazy [__] cuz
they've seen it work for other people
over the years but having had put the
work in I wouldn't I wouldn't have
bullshitted youself n for sure now yeah
you played me a version of the album
about two years ago uh in Atlanta and uh
some of the stuff made it some of the
stuff is didn't make it but you've
definitely for people who don't know
like uh and haven't heard you speak
about the album you describe it as kind
of like your uh Wolverine origin story
yeah yeah Ronald jewes is very much the
X-Men it's like the uncy X-Men any
number of characters will pop up and in
and out and um you know depending on who
your favorite character was you knew
their Origins where they came from and
stuff Wolverine had always been one of
mine Logan I love Magneto is the reason
part of the reason I name my company
villains M yeah Magneto is part of the
reason I even call my company villains
because I believe villains aren't
necessarily bad guys you know what I
mean they just have a different agenda
in terms of solving the big problem but
all that to say run the Jews man rest in
peace to Lola you know what I'm saying
gangster Buu Zack de laoka Josh ham M
Staples two chains big boy all these
people have been a part of the run the
Jews universe and um I realized that my
character Killer Mike this bad
swaggering dope ass MC that essentially
is 9-year-old kid named Michael created
and built out of his imagination the
story of Michael had never gotten told I
never people didn't know where kill
might came from or why you know people
interpreted confidence his arrogance and
[__] like that but you know when you
grow up in in the middle of hip-hop Hip
Hop's you know been around 50 years but
it's been giving a lot of a lot of kids
a lot of little boys you know a reason
to hold their chin up Swagger so you
know I had to realize that I had to
introduce myself to people that's yeah I
mean cuz it this is your first solo
album since rap music yes 11 years yeah
that's crazy and for people who don't
know rap music is what really what
kicked off run the jewels yep yep y it's
the pre-run the jewels yeah yeah um and
and it's crazy to think like I feel like
11 years ago was three years ago yeah it
does it feels three years ago yeah it
does but it's crazy like we've had a a
pretty crazy historical run that you've
been a part of with LP and like you know
I know you took your time with this
project and I'm just I'm just glad man
that like the Grammys got got it right I
feel like a couple of years ago like you
know there was a couple of Grammy
nominations that I I was glad to see
Royce got nominated and Freddy Gibbs got
nominated and when they nominated you a
couple of times this year I was like
thank God cuz well three times yep yep
two four um rap song of the year rap
performance of the year in sciences and
engine and then at rap album of the year
and that's what that's what I you know
um I ain't going to lie I want it I I I
want rap album of the year cuz I'm proud
to be a rapper yeah you know I'm damn
proud to be a rapper a lot of people you
know they um they get rap album of the
year and they act like that's a snub you
know what I'm saying people have acted
as though in the past well I deserve the
album of the year Well I personally feel
like yeah I gave you the album of the
year in terms of depth of human
emotion vulnerability Stell I gave you
what music is supposed to give you
whether it's the blues or rock and roll
or Soul or Funk or rap I gave that to
you but I care and covet rap of the rap
album of the year because for the last
50 years this has been a driving you
know cultural force in this in this
country you know rap wasn't even my
music first it was my mom's music my mom
was only 16 when she had me so the First
music I'm hearing from her is Disco and
early rap records you know so it matters
to me because of what rockim gave to me
Eric being and rockim because of what
rund DMC gave to me because what Outcast
and Goody Mob gave to me because of what
Nas first two LPS especially gave to me
you know when you start talking about
Far Side what they gave to me D and
hieroglyphics they gave to me I win that
award I'm going to be the proudest
person to have ever held that award you
know because I give a damn about being a
rapper and an MC this is not a secondary
job this ain't some [__] I did cuz I
couldn't play sports this is not that's
no like to anyone I was just too chubby
to play sports what's your frame of
reference Mike some of my best friends
won an NCA Championship UCLA one of my
other best friends got got got drafted
to the Buffalo Bills my friends dolphin
so I knew yeah I ain't gonna be no
athlete I'm G be I'm G be the best
goddamn rapper out of my friend group so
I care and and I think that um a lot of
mcing is based on these days is kind of
acting as though you don't care but I
care I want it I also think like you
have one of the more unique paths to a
Grammy nomination if you just look at
the way your career played out like
obviously coming out with Outcast and
the whole world is where a lot of people
were introduced to you uh obviously you
know your first album was incredible and
I feel like your first album isn't on
Spotify monster I don't know I don't
even I don't think monsters I still ride
old school so I I listen to Monster cuz
I'm pretty sure not on your Spotify
account I still ride CDs I still ride
old school so um but no but it's crazy
and then you have your gr your Grind
Time rap rap [__] where you're dropping
mixtapes and you're dropping records
like like you you you you were really on
your [__] I mean I first heard pill
through you and a bunch of a bunch of
young artists out of Atlanta I
discovered through those projects and
then rap music is one of the best rap
albums ever in my opinion so and it
kicks off this whole Unexpected Journey
of run the jewels y last decade me and
LP
and you know in a in a world in which
rap groups Duos Etc don't exist anymore
yeah you guys have thrived in a way that
like really it's like y'all and the
Amigos yeah shouts out to the Migos rest
in peace of takeoff shouts out to Quon
and for you to take all this time to
kind of reintroduce the world to Michael
yeah and get the acknowledgement get the
nod man it's just a beautiful thing to
see so man I appreciate you I appre I
want it so you know y'all y'all send me
some prayer some good energy and hope we
mve on people hearts on there you know
vote for fote for the person who first
of all again has put put together the
rap album of the year and beyond that I
really I really give a damn about it
yeah and like uh I always so so like
obviously when I first heard the album I
always wonder a couple of things cuz you
and your lady are amazing you guys are
you know obviously you uh she's she's
been talked about by you a lot I've met
your wife a lot she's cool as hell Shay
biger when did you give Shay a heads up
about the summer record like hey I'm
going to write I'm going to write this
song about this exf fling from back in
the day no it was my fing was my
girlfriend my yeah I don't hey guys ball
up now don't just be be a real [__]
about [__] you know what I mean and you
just your wife was in love with somebody
before she met you even if she was eight
and you one of one it's very rare that
that actually is the case hey man your
grandparents say they was but my my you
know yeah I cannot know my Grandad my
Grandmama was a virgin I can't tell you
my grandfather was you know just saying
so you know I um such a dope
storytelling record though yeah she had
already heard the story because we
talked that's my friend of course you
know so I I I think that that um it
wasn't a need to to um say hey I'm going
to rap about this I think I think she
was just like you finally got a chance
to get it off your chest yeah cuz it's
something that's that I've been with and
it's been with me and it's sat with me
and when I played the record from Men
And for those who might not know what
he's talking about that you shouldn't be
out there but you know give Slumber a
listen it's a story of me at 156 fall in
love with a girl who's a year too
younger than me and us living like
adults essentially for two summers I'm
you know I'm thinking I'm trapping on
Rich you know she in the apartment so
subsidized so a like we got many bills
but we live like adults and we we and we
get pregnant and I have to go through
the the abortion process you know with
her paying for it and um man I played it
for dudes and dudes wept and they say
man nobody had ever expressed how I felt
you know I hadn't even been considered
that I had feelings and we knew it was
traumatic for the girl for the woman
absolutely it is and they deserve all
the empathy and all the support around
controlling their bodies they deserve
but man them little boys and them men
and these young men that have had to
take part in that there is nobody
sometimes to put the arm around the
shoulders so I know that was a difficult
decision to make and I know it's going
it's going to stay with you or let me
tell you it's going to stay with you you
know you're going to feel away about it
you know so I was honored to be able to
do it and my and my my my wife is glad I
got it out my chest you know now she
like now you can stop talking now
you world knows the story now yeah
uh for you man you have a lot of
vulnerable moments on this album
obviously uh motherless to me is like
one that really um really stands out I
know I want to say when you played the
album for people who don't know you had
like a really cool album listening thing
here in La that was at like a masonic
temple or it was it was it was a
cemetery it was at a cemetery a masonic
it was a cemetery but I remember just
walking
Illuminati like yo you join the
Illuminati that's why you got the
gravity yeah exactly that's hanging out
with
Freemon um but no I know you got really
emotional talking about that the record
cuz it's about your mom you know what
I'm saying yeah my girl man Denise she
she under here her and my grandmother my
mother was 16 years old when she she had
me and um you know we just grew up
together that was my girl you know like
that's the first person that introduced
me to rap music that's she was I mean
being 16 she's also kind of your friendo
yeah she was like my big sister you know
what I'm saying that's who taught me how
to dance with a girl right you know what
I'm saying that's who taught me how to
how to approach a girl you like that's
who that's who taught me how to take no
[__] you know don't be no sucker and she
wasn't no single mom you know my I had
two dads you know my dad who's
biologically my dad and my dad she
married I had grandparents that raised
me grew up in a you know a man and woman
household raising me and my two little
sisters but me and my mom just shared
this special bond and friendship in
kinship and it was around you know her
saying you know I wish I could be sof
thr you about some stuff but you're the
only boy I got so you got to be man but
at her heart she was an artist so she
she encouraged that about me you know
what I mean so I just man I just I want
to I want to lead a life that makes her
proud Essen for you um looking at the
nominees of rap album of the year yeah
the motherless record I'm sorry that
record just to say I got emotional about
that record cuz cuz I miss her so
anybody out there who has a mother no
matter your relationship check in on cuz
I think we take advantage of those
things my mom my mom told me she said
you know I I know you think your
grandmother is your mama cuz she she
raised you but I'm your [__] mama
that's that's kind of conversation you
have and she said and when I go when I
go you going to understand it and the
day she died I've never felt that
emptiness and and I know it doesn't get
filled and a lot of people don't realize
that until that day happen it's happened
yeah I didn't [__] she told me yeah you
know I I you know I I I I you know I
tithe and and and make my offerings I I
I you know I I got to
I got a place in my house where I honor
but with that said like man I wish I
could have said it while she was here I
get it it's such a beautiful song it
really I mean that's a record that I
feel like could have been nominated for
a Grammy it could have been it could
have been should have been would have
been will be one day who knows you know
remixed album or something but I just
know I got to to cover it all album of
the Year 100% and an album to live to
yeah I was going to say who do you see
as uh if you're looking at the other
nominees for rap album of the year yeah
I got my opinion but who do you think is
the album you got to worry about I don't
know I I just know that I've listened to
them all and I I like parts of all of
them you know and I respect the artist
involved but what I'm saying is as as I
could sit down Drake and Savage I could
sit down Nas I could sit down Travis
Metro boom and I could sit down with
Metro I said Metro last cuz the producer
he put together Mars I could put those
artists in a room and I could play my
album and something about my experience
in my life is going to affect all of
them out that Al in a deeply personal
way and I you know what I mean like you
know in a deeply personal way and and I
don't say that to be in competition with
but just saying I made an album that we
all can bleed to I made an album that we
all understand addiction we all
understand the precious preciousness of
a mother we all are black men in North
America trying to understand and make
our way I don't care what color um Drake
is in terms of how people argue about
his bir raciality and [__] since he's
been Coming to America he knows he's a
black man if he been in Atlanta he knows
he's a black man if he been in Houston
or Memphis so there's something on here
for the worker class the black men and
the women who love them for all of us so
I believe that if we sat down at a table
I could have that argument with those
men and say this is why like amongst the
fraternity and Brotherhood of MC's at
their table this is why this is why I
should and listen to this and it'll
pierce your heart the same way it's
piercing the audience's heart for sure
man I think it was a an like almost like
a much needed Medicine of of Hip Hop
it's like somebody actually is making it
a vulnerable album to like live to not
to turn up to not to tick Tok to it's
just well I mean you can still do it all
I mean the intro of down by law made a
Tik Tok I was like God damn I'm going
have to get in shape everybody gym [__]
was you know the journey Rico talking
and and and with that said exit 9 you
cruise to this a record you play and 56
minutes later after you drive from Hit
Pomona man you've like I've just had
experience I feel like I saw a movie
this is this is an album where when you
clean up your house by the time the
album end you done finish that chore man
your laundry done and folded it is a it
is a classic album in that it feels good
even the sad parts even the parts that
make you think about a reminisce on
stuff that but it makes you feel good
you feel more human after it so you know
I'm I'm just glad to be the conduent for
that energy because hip hop deserved
that in his 50th year in the 50th year
sure in the 50th year yeah for sure when
people are talking about what sales are
down and y yaad y I didn't I didn't know
[__] about sales when I first heard hip
hop I just knew I felt something when I
heard it it made me feel something and
and that's what I did